hallo mein name ist luca und ich hab
gerade echt richtig hunger herzlich
willkommen hier am donnerstag ich bin
mir derzeit nur im vorproduzieren wegen
urlaub und klausur mit dem ganzen steht
herzlich willkommen zu einem video und
zwar minecraft clever bot
beziehungsweise minecraft minnerop ort
heißt es um genau zu sein von gaming pc
5 bzw
minecraft die haben das ganze gemacht
findet einen link zum download der welt
zu deren kanal et cetera natürlich alles
in der beschreibung die haben das ganze
video betitelt als minecraft clever bot
und zwar erstmal was ist das was heißt
dem inneren robert was denn jetzt hier
eigentlich für schatten die hier ach das
ist diese konstruktion dahin wie das
ganze gebaute als macht das ganze auch
denn hier lasst euch von den schatten
wenig irritieren also wir gehen erst mal
hier auf die platte drauf und ihr seht
schon zvm minecraft mineral robert gibbs
am samstag und andere servers and eliot
ist ein work empfindet also ich sollte
irgendwas geben was wir unter der erde
gefunden haben
und der wird mir sagen was das ist wo
man das finden kann und ein paar
informationen darüber
das heißt das ist quasi klamotten
eingeschränkt man kann natürlich kein
komplettes clever bot system in
minecraft machen weil clever bot ist
eine website und die beansprucht
internet und wenn ihr dann kein internet
gegeben wäre weil man minecraft offline
spielt dann wäre das ganze natürlich
blöd weil das ging nicht auf das
internet zugreifen kann und das hat er
keine eigene keinen eigenen algorithmus
eingebaut ist auch scheißegal jedenfalls
kann ich jetzt hier darauf zugreifen
und wenn ich den jetzt beispielsweise
hier mal ein golderz gebe und dass der
einleger seht ihr heute schon der rat
ein bisschen und jetzt wird mir hier im
chat gesagt gold tores mittelblock
kommen iv und bist als download tipp
underground joseline wayne auf vorbis
aid blogs das heißt jetzt auf das gold
bezogen das ist ein mineralien block der
wird meistens in irgendwelchen
steinblöcken gefunden irgendwo ganz weit
unten
meistens in einem zweig von vier bis
acht gold blöcken
es tritt nur auf zwischen den höhen 32
also in den in den unteren 32 blöcken in
den unteren 32 ebenen und dann stehen da
noch ein paar mehr informationen sowie
prozent und so weiter und so fort und
steht auch demi moore beim master und
ihr seht schon ich habe mein gold erst
blog zurückbekommen wenn ich ihn jetzt
beispielsweise einen diamanten
gehörte schon wieder der rat hat wieder
und der schweiz beim ein diamant blog
hier wieder raus so dass die natürlich
wieder zurückbekommen und ihr sehen im
chat david james dead drop the dinosaurs
meint danke lieber clever bot diamond
ist considered one of the most valuable
value of the most valuable values and
the game to you tube city ims crafting
material also so blabla das ist der
krasseste block mit der höchsten
währungen etwa ilove diamonds ok also
sagt haben quasi bei jedem block
jemandem untergrund findet so ein paar
informationen ich könnte jetzt auch noch
reisen oder kohle oder lapislazuli oder
redstone oder smaragd reinschmeißen
allerdings schaut mal was passiert wenn
ich einen eichenholz darein schmeiße
dann sagt er euch nämlich im chat und er
gibt uns jeden moment unseren blog
zurück wenn er genau das unser eichen
blog aber wenn ich darin dann gehen dann
irgendwie mal in wismar kein tool
beispielsweise nicht einmal zwei stück
rohr und so weiter und so fort das heißt
muss meinem ressort alter du kleine
mistet wo sind meine emerald wo sind
meine e mails
ja meine lieben freunde das war alles
was dieser minerale bord clever bot in
etwa kann ich zeige euch sommer hier
oben wie das ganze gebaut wurde das ist
von minecraft budget finden müsst
wirklich sagen ich muss dazu sagen dass
ist von 2013 also schon zwei jahre her
das ist richtig krass hier sehen wir das
ganze gemacht das heißt für die ganzen
verschiedenen blöcke wir haben ihr
beispielsweise das für kempf gefahr und
in welcher form ob 32 das heißt es wäre
wahrscheinlich für lapislazuli gewesen
denke ich mal und hier steht das quasi
zu allen blöcken das heißt in jedem
dingen steht quasi in anspruch denn hier
stehen diese statements und so weiter
und so fort ich finde es sehr cool es
ist zwar sehr sehr simpel und es kann
noch sehr wenige sachen es wäre cool
wenn sam über jeden blog was sagen
könnte aber das wäre natürlich dann das
ganze mal 100 so nett war heute mal
etwas kürzeres video weil ich echt zu
viel zeit und sehr viel noch vor
produzieren muss wenn es euch allerdings
gefallen hat will ich nicht immer nur
wert und vor allem findet links nation
der beschreibung und wir sehen uns
bestimmt mal wieder natürlich